ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
เรียนทุกคนก็
โอเคไหม
รอบคอโอเคมั้ยอ่าขอโอเคนิดหน่อยค่ะนิด
หน่อยอะไรเก่งน้ำดื่มน้ำ
ก็มาเจอกับเรา 2 คนนะคะครูฟ้าวันนี้วัน
อะไร
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะวันนี้วันจันทร์วัน
จันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันจันทร์ที่ 3 เดือน
มกราคม
ค่ะเดือนมกราคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่เป็น
เดือนที่ 1 ค่ะโอ้ตีผชปี
เปลี่ยนแล้วไม่ใช่
2564 ไม่ใช่แล้วเปลี่ยน 2 แล้วปีคศราคา
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะและขอสก็เปลี่ยน
2  0 ไม่ใช่ดีใหม่แล้วน้องไหม
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันอาทิตย์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอาทิตย์ที่ 2
เดือนมกราคม
เป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือนที่ 1
ค่ะปีพต 2565
อุ้ยดีคศ 2
022  2 แล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันอังคารที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันอังคารที่ 4 เดือน
มกราคม
เป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือนที่ 1
ค่ะปีพตตปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศ 2
[เพลง]
แล้วตอนนี้ฮาๆตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครู
ฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
9 โมงค่ะ 9 โมงกี่นาที
09:50 น 3 นาทีนอ่ะแต่9โมง 53 นาทีนเป็น
เวลาตอนเช้าน้องของปี้
แยกดีใช่แล้วเนี่ยผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็เลยจะมี
เกมมันเล็กรูฟ้าเช็คอะไรคะเช็คว่าเช็คตา
ตาครูฟ้า
ตา
เช็คตาของครูฟ้าแล้วก็เช็คว่าเช็คที่นี่
เช็คสมองสมัครโครงฟ้า
เรื่องที่ดีเนาะ
จะไม่ได้เช็ค IQ นะ
เช็คว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยตาตาดูดวงเสร็จแล้วก็
ฟ้าเนี่ยจำได้ไหมมาครูฟ้าเนี่ย
นักเรียนคะอ่ะฮะโอเค
เช็คตาน้ำตาครูฟ้าผู้หญิงจะมีรูปให้ครู
ฟ้าและดูว่าฟ้าใช้ตาดู
ก็จะ B เวลาจะไม่คะ
วินาทีนะสิมิลาทีเป็นจะนับ 1  2  3  4  5
6  7  8  9  10 สมัยเสร็จครูฝาต้องเช็ค
จะเช็คว่าครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมว่าครูป๊าเนี่ย
เห็นดูแล้วเนี่ยเห็นอะไรบ้าง
ได้เลยค่ะผู้หญิงได้เลยเนาะครูฟ้าพร้อมนะ
คะ
กระดานมีปากกามีไหม
หน้ากระดานและประกา
rokukyu69 นาทีมาคะโอเคนะคะคือฟ้าโอเค
ค่ะหนึ่งสองสามโอเคค่ะ 1  2  3  4  5  6
7  8
9  10
นครบแล้ว 10 วินาทีครูฟ้าดูแล้วจำอะไรได้
ฟ้าเห็นอะไรบ้างมีอะไรบ้างในรูปคะมีต้น
ไม้ห่ามีต้นไม้
มีรู้
มีรู้ว่ามีรูรั่วมี
มีรั้วคอนกรีตล้อม
เล่นเพลงร็
วิ่งไล่จับวิ่งไล่จับเด็กคนนี้เล่น get
บ่
คนนี้กระโดดเชือกการกระโดดเชื่อ
จำได้นิดหน่อยค่ะ
นก 8 หมดหรือยังคะหมดหรือยังที่ครูป๊าจำ
ได้
หมดแล้วหมดแล้วค่ะหมดแล้วเดี๋ยวมันอะไร
รูปแรกไงอ่าคุณจะมาดูนะว่าที่ครูฟ้าจำได้
เนี่ยถูกไหมใช่ไหมมีต้นไม้
เออมีรูรั่วค่ะน้องรู้มีเครื่องเล่นกู
ซะจำได้มีเด็กหนึ่งสองสามสี่ห้าหกเจ็ดแปด
เก้า
ฟ้าก็แบบไม่อ่าใส่เอ้
8989 ใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็มีเด็กเล่น
สเก็ตบอร์ดช่วยที่กูฟ้าจำได้มีเด็กเล่น
กระโดดเชื่อกระดูไม่มีเด็ก 2 คนวิ่งไล่
กันหมูครูฟ้าก็จำได้เยอะนะเนี่ย
อยู่มา
หน่อยใส่ค่ะ
รู้ต่อไปลบกับ
โอเค
รูปต่อไปถ้านักเรียนเนาะอยากเล่นเกม
เหมือนครูฟ้าก็ได้นะเช็คนักเรียนก็อาจจะ
มี
อากากระดาษมาเล่นอ่ะโอเคคุยเองจะไม่เวลา
10 วินาทีนะคะคือฟ้าพร้อมไหมคะพร้อมกับ
เด้อ
523 โอเคค่ะหนึ่งสองสามสี่ห้าหกเจ็ดแปด
เก้าสิบ
ครบแล้วครูฟ้าดูรูปแล้วเห็นอะไรบ้างจำ
อะไรได้บ้าง
เอ่อเด็กขาวเด็ก RB เด็ก
เด็กที่ครูฟ้าเห็นครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมเด็กผู้
ชาย
หรือเด็กผู้หญิง
เด็กผู้หญิงน่ะโหคุณด้วย
ใช่เด็กผู้หญิงอา
[เพลง]
แล้วครูฟ้าจำและไหมว่ามีเด็กผู้หญิงกี่คน
เด็ก
ผู้หญิง 1 คนหน้าแล้วเด็กมีอะไรอีกนอกจาก
เด็กผู้หญิงคุณฟ้าเห็นเด็กผู้หญิงแล้ว
เห็นอะไรอีกคะมีตุ๊กตาหมีอ่ะ
หือ
พี่ตุ๊กตาหมีแล้วมีอะไรอีก
อะไรไม่รู้อ่ะจำไม่ได้ใช่ไหมมองไม่เห็น
หนูไม่เห็นมันคืออะไรมี
ถ้วยแก้วกาแฟค่ะพี่แก้วมาก
[เพลง]
มี
อะไรคะ
กล่องหาไม่มีกล่อง
กล่องนะใส่
ข้างในกล่องมีอะไรจำได้ไหม
ตุ๊กตาไหม
มี 2 ตัว
3 ตัว
อ่ะหมดแล้วนะกูฟ้าจอดได้เท่านี้ขอกลับจำ
อะไรได้ไหมคะ
พรุ่งนี้มีถ้วยอีก
มีทองท้อน
อันนี้ช้อนนะสอน
ซ่อมหวังชน
[เพลง]
มีอะไรอีกล่ะมีอะไรอีกมีอะไรอีกจำได้ไหม
ที่เห็น
จำไม่ได้แล้วค่ะหมดแล้วใช่ไหมอ่ะเดี๋ยว
เรามาดู
น้องมาดูพบผู้หญิงเรื่องขยายรูปให้กูฟ้า
ในรูป
พอดีเด็กผู้หญิง 1 คนสวยกูก็มีตุ๊กตา
มีถ้วยกาแฟ 2 ถ้วยน้องให้แต่ว่ามีแค่ช้อน
นะคะไม่มีสอบเธอตรงนี้ก็คือเป็นมาดินสอสี
ดินสอสีแล้วก็เป็ด is มีกาน้ำชา
สมัยแล้วก็คือฟ้าวบอกว่ามีกล่อง
ลองในกล่องมีตุ๊กตา 1  2  3
แต่ว่ามีเป็ดสวยไฟฟ้าจำไม่ได้ว่ามีเป็ด
โอเคนะกูฟ้าจำได้เยอะมากๆๆๆ
ฉลาดนักเรียนจำได้หรือเปล่าน่ะจำได้ไหมคะ
มีอะไรบ้าง
ลบ
รูปต่อไปรูปต่อไปเดี๋ยวพี่จะขยายให้กูฟ้า
นิดนึงนะคะมันก็จะเห็นชัดๆเนาะโอเครูปต่อ
ไปครูครับพร้อมนะคะพร้อมค่ะหนึ่งสองสาม
โอเคนะคะ
2  2  3  4  4  5  5  6  6  7  8  9  10
[เพลง]
ครูฟ้าดูรูปแล้วดูฟ้าเห็นอะไรบ้างตำอะไร
ได้บ้าง
ได้เลยห่าค่ะในรูปครูฟ้าเห็นอะไรบ้างคะ
ป้าเห็นคุณแม่ค่ะอ่ามีคุณแม่
แม่เนี่ย
เออคุณแม่ทำอะไรกูพระจำได้ไหมคุณแม่ทำ
อะไร
พ่อคุณแม่กำลังทำซุปอือ
เพราะมีหม้อ
จบ
แล้วก็มีเด็กอ๋อมีเด็ก
ครูบาจำได้ไหมว่ามีเด็กกี่คนมีเด็กอะไรคะ
เนี่ยสองคนค่ะ
มีเด็ก 2 คนเด็ก 2 คนเนี่ยเป็นเด็กผู้ชาย
หรือว่าเด็กผู้หญิงคะเด็กผู้หญิง 1 คนน่ะ
อ๋อ
เด็กผู้หญิงอันนี้ไข่เอาเด็กผู้หญิงเด็ก
ผู้หญิงทำอะไร
ทำไข่เจียวเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงทำไข่ผู้หญิงทำ
ไข่แล้วก็มีไข่ไข่ไข่ไข่นี่แครอท
ครูฟ้าเห็นแครอท
ถ้ามีอะไรอย่างต้นหอม
หือมีหัวอะไรก็ไม่รู้ให้กลมๆ
คืออะไรไม่รู้คืออะไรอ่ะนี่งงอ๋อๆนะคะตรง
นี้เป็นเด็กผู้ชายแล้วก็มีเด็กผู้ชายด้วย
เด็กผู้ชาย 1 คนใช่ไหมครูขาเห็นเด็กผู้
ชายหนึ่งคนน่ะ
เด็กผู้ชายนะฮะ
แล้วเด็กผู้ชายทำอะไรครูฟ้าจำได้ไหม
ผู้ชายหั่นผัก
หั่นภาพนะคะมี
มิกซ์เอกผู้ชายเขามีเขียงหรอมีเขียง
อันกำลังหั่นหั่นผักอยู่
หมดเรียนรู้จำได้อีกไหมมี
อาร์มหมดแล้วหมดแล้วหมดแล้วค่ะมาดูเนาะใน
รูปมีคุณแม่เหนื่อยภูฟ้าก็มีคุณแม่คุณแม่
กำลังต้มซุปต้มซุปแล้วหนีเด็กผู้หญิงเด็ก
ผู้หญิงเด็กผู้หญิงแล้วก็กำลังทำไข่เนาะ
แล้วก็มีไข่ไข่ไข่โอ้วเก่งมากนะจำได้แล้ว
ก็ตรงนี้มีแครอทใช่ไหมแล้วมี
ต้นหอม
ประจำได้แล้วก็คือว่าอะไรไม่รู้กลมกลมสี
เหลืองมะเขือเทศมะเขือเทศ
เราจะเป็นชีสรู๊ดนะคะแล้วก็มีเหตุอยู่ใน
ถ้วยเพราะเหตุหรออะไรเหตุไม่ใช่ Beet
Root น้ำขิงก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันเนาะอันนี้
เป็น this  route
คะแล้วก็คือฟ้าก็บอกว่ามีเด็กผู้ชายสมัย
เด็กผู้ชายกำลังหั่นผักหั่นแตงกวาหรอมี
มิมี่แล้วก็มีเขียงนะคะโอ้โห
เก่งมากครูฟ้า
อีกหนึ่งโรค
ได้ค่ะแต่ว่านี้ให้เวลาแค่ถ้าวินาทีได้
ไหมได้หาผู้หญิงอันนี้ไม่ยากไม่ยากมีนิด
หน่อย
โอเคนะคะครูฟ้าพร้อมนะเพราะของอ่ะพร้อมนะ
คะหนึ่งสอง
สามโอเคค่ะ 1  2  2  3  3  4  4  5
โอเคโอเคครูฟ้าดูรูปแล้วเห็นอะไรบ้างใน
รูปอ่าเห็นเด็กผู้หญิงอ่ะ
ในรูปมีเด็กผู้หญิง
เด็กผู้หญิง 1 คน 2 คน 3 คนคะเด็กผู้หญิง
1 คน
เด็กผู้หญิง 1 คนทำอะไร
รดน้ำต้นไม้ค่ะ
[เพลง]
รดน้ำต้นไม้นี้มีต้นไม้ใช่มั้ยห่ามีต้น
ไม้กี่ต้นคะกูฟ้าสีฟ้าเห็น
หนึ่งมั้ง 1 ต้นคู่ฟ้าคิดว่าหนึ่งต้นที่ 2
ฟ้าไม่ได้น่าจะประมาณนี้นะคะแล้วก็น้อง
บิ๊กใครอีกไหมในรูปนี้เด็กผู้ชาย
เด็กผู้ชายกี่คนในรูปมีเด็กผู้ชายกี่คน
เด็กผู้ชายอีกคนหนึ่งคนเหมือนกันแล้วจำ
ได้ไหมว่าเด็กผู้ชายทำอะไรในรูปเด็กผู้
ชายกำลังขุดต้นไม้
[เพลง]
ขอสั้นจ๊ะ
กำลัง
ถือ
รั่วรั่ว
เราพูดขุดต้นไม้อยู่
พูดต้นไม้อยู่นะ
หมดหรือยังอ่า
มีอะไรอีกไหม
ไม่มีแล้วนะที่มีแล้วใช่ไหมคะอ่ะโอเคมาดู
ซิว่าครูฟ้าจำได้ขนาดไหนมาดูในรูปในรูป
ครับมีเด็กผู้หญิง 1 คนสมัยถืออันนี้เลย
ค่ะก้า
ตำรวจบุกรัวๆ
บัวรดน้ำถือบัวรดน้ำกำลังรดน้ำต้นไม้ในรถ
หมายแค่หนึ่งต้นมีแค่หนึ่งต้นใด her ต้น
ไม้มี 1 ต้นขายกำลังเด็กผู้หญิงและกำลัง
รดน้ำต้นไม้แล้วก็มีโครงฟ้าบอกในรูปมี
เด็กผู้ชาย 1 คนใช่ไหมมีพวกกำลังขุดดิน
ขุดดินฉันกำลังขุดดินนั้นเรียกว่าพวกหน้า
ขาอ่าแต่ว่าจริงในรูปเด็กผู้ชายเนี่ยใส่
หมวกด้วยไหมใส่บอกด้วย
นะ
น้องก็ในรูปนี้คือเด็กผู้ชายเด็กผู้หญิง
เนี่ยกำลังรดน้ำต้นไม้แล้วก็พรวนดินขุด
ดินอยู่นะคะอากู๋
ครูหมาเก่งมากจำได้เยอะ
ไหมจำนัดนะฮะกูฟ้าดูแล้วไม่ไหวดูผู้หญิง
มีเวลาให้ดู
ฟ้าก็จำได้ว่ารูปที่ครูฟ้าดูก็จะมีอะรูป
แรกใช่ไหมค่ะก็จะมีเด็กๆอยู่ที่
อยู่ที่ขอโทษนักเรียนเด็กๆอยู่ที่สนาม
เด็กเล่นสวยที่สนามเด็กเล่นใช่ไหมค่ะนิด
รูปแรกเนาะหน้าแล้วก็รูป 2 นะฮะก็คือเป็น
รูปเด็กผู้หญิงแล้วก็มีของเล่นสมัยของ
เล่นของเล่นของเขา
แล้วก็รูปที่ 3 ก็คือมีคุณแม่แล้วก็ลูก
กำลังทำอาหาร
ใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็รู้สึกท้ายก็คือมีเด็กผู้
ชายเด็กผู้หญิงมี 2 คนกำลังแม่น้ำต้นไม้
ปลูกต้นไม้สายรักนักเรียนจำได้เหมือนครู
ฟ้าไว้หรือว่าจำได้มากกว่าครูฟ้า
กว่า
6 ได้นะคะคอมเม้นท์บอกได้นะคะส่วนวันนี้
น้องเราสองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้าน้องบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ